good afternoon before i begin today's
announcement
uh let me take a few moments to thank
all the law enforcement folks for all
they did the military personnel
from all across the federal state and
local agencies that
secured yesterday's inaugural activities
and a special thanks to the members of
the national guard from around the
country
it was an unprecedented situation hope
will
never have to be renewed again and
everyone
can handle with the most professionalism
and duty and honor
that you could be expected the president
as president as commander-in-chief i
always
respect and revere their service and
that of their families
but now to today's announcement
vice president harris and i were joined
by members of our
kova 19 team response team and dr tony
fauci our
chief covered medical advisor javier
bacera
excuse me our nominee for secretary of
health and human services
dr vivek murthy our nominee for surgeon
general
dr rochelle wolinski uh she's going to
be the director
for the centers for disease control
prevention and
dr marcelo nunez smith who will be
leading our equity work and the coveted
response
and jeff zeins and natalie quillin who
are managing this whole effort
yesterday yesterday during my inaugural
address
i offered a salient prayer and of silent
prayer it was both salient and silent
i thought it was important that people
understand what had happened
that we all pay tribute to the our
prayers for those 400
000 americans who've lost their lives in
this pandemic
on tuesday uh jill and i kamel and doug
we stood at the reflecting pool
in front of the lincoln memorial and
joined americans all across the country
to remember those four hundred thousand
moms and dads husbands and wives
children
sons daughters and i said at that moment
that to heal we must remember
to heal we must remember it's important
to do that as a nation
we must also act though not just
remember
yet for the past year we couldn't rely
on the federal government to act with
the urgency
and focus and coordination we needed and
we have seen the tragic cost of that
failure
three to four thousand deaths per day
to date more than 24 million americans
24 million americans have been infected
to put that in context
america makes up four percent of the
world's population
but 25 percent of the world's confirmed
covet 19 cases
and nearly 20 percent of all the covet
19
deaths when we have four percent of the
world's population
the pandemically the pandemic excuse me
has disproportionately
impacted on blacks latinos and native
americans
who are about four times as likely to be
hospitalized and nearly three times more
likely to die
from the kova 19 pandemic than
white americans hospitals are out of
beds
businesses are closed for good schools
are caught in between and while the
vaccines provide
so much hope the rollout has been a
dismal failure thus far
so i understand the despair and
frustration of so many americans
and how they're feeling i understand why
many governors
mayors county officials tribal leaders
feel like they're
left on their own without a clear
national plan to get them through the
crisis
let me be very clear things are going to
continue to get worse before they
get better the memorial we we held
two nights ago will not be our last one
unfortunately
the death toll will likely top 500 000
next month the cases will continue to
mount
we didn't get into this mess overnight
and it's going to take months for us to
turn things around
but let me be equally clear we will
get through this we will defeat this
pandemic
and to a nation waiting for action let
me be the clearest on this point
help is on the way today
today i am unveiling a national strategy
on covet 19
and executive actions to beat this
pandemic
this plan reflects the ideas i set
forward during the campaign
and further refined over the past three
months
it consists of my transitions teams the
task force tony fauci and the team
here today and other experts put this
plan together
our national strategy is comprehensive
it's based on science not politics
it's based on truth not denial and it's
detail
you can review this entire plan this
entire plan
by going to whitehouse.gov it is so
detailed it is over
100 it's 198 pages and
and and from complete detail what we're
going to do
our plan starts with mounting an
aggressive safe
and effective vaccination campaign to
meet our goal of administering
100 million shots and our first hundred
days in office we're on day one
this will be one of the greatest
operational challenges our nation has
ever undertaken
and i'm committed to getting it done
we're committed to getting it done
and i explained as i explained last week
we'll move
heaven and earth to get more people
vaccinated
for free and create more places for them
to get vaccinated
to mobilize more medical teams to get
shots on people's arms and to increase
vaccine supply and get it out the door
as fast as possible
yesterday we got started we directed the
federal
emergency management agency fema to
start standing up
the first federally supported community
vaccination centers
with the goal of standing up 100 centers
within the next month
the centers for disease control and
prevention will launch the federal
pharmacy program
to make vaccines available to
communities in their local pharmacies
beginning early within the i think by
the 7th or 8th of february
but in very early february we'll also
test the department of health and human
services to prepare and
expand the pool of medical professionals
who can administer the vaccine who can
administer the vaccine
and to ensure we have enough vaccinators
the people doing the vaccines
to meet the nation's needs and quickly
in addition to this effort our
administration
will be asking congress to fund the
for for the funds to grow the public
health
workforce we also are going to take
immediate steps to partner with
governors mayors and other local
officials who we've been talking to all
along
who are on the front lines of this fight
we direct we redirected fema to
establish a covet response liaison
for each state which means every state
will have a point person
at the federal level to maximize
cooperation between the federal
government
and the states and where it falls short
to be made known about it
may be made known immediately this is a
model
we use to respond to hurricanes
hurricane sandy which i was deeply
involved with
and in just a few moments i'm going to
sign a declaration
to immediately begin reimbursing states
100 percent for the use of their
national guards to help covert relief
efforts
something democrats and republican
governors alike
have called for but the brutal truth is
it's going to take months before we can
get the majority of americans vaccinated
so while we increase vaccinations
we're going to take steps necessary now
to slow the spread of the disease as
well
one of our 100-day challenges is
asking the american people to mask up
for the first hundred days the next 99
days
the mass could become a partisan issue
unfortunately
but it's a patriotic act but for a few
months to wear a mask
no vaccines the fact is that the single
best thing we can do they're
more important than the vaccines because
they take time to work
and if we do this as americans the
experts say by wearing a mask
from now until april we'd save more than
50
000 lives going forward 50 000 lives
so i'm asking every american to mask up
for the next hundred days yesterday i
signed an executive action
that requires mass and social distancing
on federal property
today we'll be signing an additional
executive action
to extend masking requirements on
interstate travel
like on trains planes and buses and
in light of the new covent variants that
we're learning about
we are we're we are and we're
instituting now
a new measure for individuals flying
into the united states
from other countries in addition to
wearing masks
everyone flying to the united states
from another country
will need to test before they get on
that plane
before they depart and quarantine when
they
arrive in america our national plan
launches a full-scale war-time effort to
address the supply shortages
by ramping up production and protective
equipment syringes needles you name it
when i say wartime people kind of look
at me like wartime
well as i said last night four
hundred thousand americans have died
that's more than have died in all of
world war
ii four hundred thousand
and this is a wartime undertaking
today i'm signing an executive action to
use the defense production
act and all other available authorities
to direct
all federal agencies and private
industry
to accelerate the making of everything
this needs to protect
test vaccinate and take care of our
people
well we've already identified suppliers
and we're working with them
to move the plan forward now look
our strategy includes a plan to safely
reopen schools and businesses
while protecting our workers today
we're directing the department of
education and the department of health
and human services
to immediately provide schools and
communities with
clear guidance and resources to safely
reopen
the schools and child care centers
we're putting and by the way when you do
that think of all the people who can get
back to work
be able to get back to work all the
mothers and single fathers are
staying home taking care of their
children
we're going to put the full force of the
federal government
behind expanding testing by launching a
covet 19
pandemic testing board this effort will
ensure that we get testing to
where it is needed and where it's needed
most helping schools and businesses
reopen safely
and protecting the most vulnerable like
those who live in long-term
long-term care facilities and for the
millions of workers
many of whom are people of color
immigrants and low-wage workers
who continue to put their lives on the
line to keep this country going through
the pandemic
i'm calling for the enforcement of a
more stringent worker safety standards
so that you are better protected from
this virus
while you have to continue to work to
protect the rest of us
our plan also protects those most at
risk and works for everyone
of all races and urban and rural
communities alike
today i'm formalizing the health equity
task force
that we announced in the transition led
by the brilliant doctor marcelo
nunes-smith
who ensures that it's going to ensure
that equality is at the core of every
decision we make
that includes addressing vaccine
hesitancy and building trust in
communities as well as
fighting disinformation campaigns that
are already underway
above all our plan is to restore public
trust
we will make sure that science and
public health
scientists and public health experts
will speak directly to you that's why
you're going to hear a lot more from dr
fauci again not from the president
but from the real genuine experts and
scientists
we're going to make sure they work free
from political interference
and they make decisions strictly based
on science
and health care alone science and health
alone
not what the political consequences are
the vice president harris and i and our
entire administration
will always be honest and transparent
with you about both the good news and
the bad
we will level with you when we make a
mistake
we'll straight up say what happened
and i said at the outset the honest
truth is
we're still in a dark winter of this
pandemic
it's going to get worse before it gets
better it's going to take many months to
get where we need to be
progress from our plan will take time to
measure as people getting infected today
they don't show up as case counts for
weeks
and those who perish from this disease
die weeks after their exposure
despite the best intentions we're going
to face setbacks
which i will always explain to you
but i also but also know we can do this
if we come together
that's why ultimately our plan is based
on
unity and all of us acting as one
nation it requires families
and neighbors looking out for one
another health care providers
and business and civic and religious and
civil rights organizations
and unions all relying together on a
common purpose with urgency and purpose
and resolve
requires reasserting our global
leadership
which is why i took an action yesterday
for the united states to rejoin the
world health organization
and to re-establish our global pandemic
office
in the national security council it
requires congress coming together to
provide the necessary funding
in the coveted relief package and the
american rescue plan that i
will soon be sending to the congress i
know these
bold practical steps will not come
cheaply
but failing to do so will cost us so
much more dearly i look forward to
working with members of both parties in
the congress
we're in a national emergency and it's
time we treat it like one
together with the national plan as the
united states of america
as i said yesterday in my inaugural
address there are moments in history
when more is asked of a particular
generation more vascular as americans
than other times
we are in that moment now
history is going to measure whether
we're up to the task
i believe we are the american people
have given
so much already but i believe they're
ready to set big goals
and pursue them with courage conviction
and
honesty because the health of the nation
is literally at stake it's not hyperbole
i'm convinced the american people are
ready as well
to spare no effort no expense to get
this done
what could be more important more people
we vaccinate
and the faster we do it the sooner we
can put this pandemic behind us
the sooner we can build our economy back
and build it back better
and get back to our lives and to our
loved ones
we can do this we can do this if we
stand together
as fellow americans as the united as the
united states of america
so god bless those lost souls in this
pandemic
and their families all they left behind
may god bless
all of you on the front lines who define
the best of who we are as americans
thank you very much now i'm going to go
to this desk and sign
these executive actions but again this
is the plan
this is the plant you can go online and
get it i know it's a lot of heavy
reading
but it's all laid out in stark detail
here
thank you
this executive order i'm signing is uh
stamping in supply chain
this next one is keeping workers safe
how to do that
this next one is ensuring equitable
response
i guess i should take these out this way
the pins are going to pop on there
can you give me a hand here there you go
this next one is i referenced about
traveling in america this is the
promoting safe travel
this nest one is setting up the pandemic
testing board
thank you
this next one is
studying safe schools initiatives
this next one is dictating the
cova data that has to be maintained and
recorded
next one is making sure
that the national guard and fema support
is available
this next home
relates to expanding access to care and
treatment for coba 19.
the last one is our
global response directive
where the u.s is right now when i
announced that you all said it's not
possible come on give me a break man
that's a good start 100 million thank
you